today's guest is a woman that
i mean a woman that really i'd be online
if i said she didn't occupy
one of my aortas a lot of times and
you know she's a very loving lady that
is part of the podcast community
and a wonderful podcast here in her own
right
and she has a new podcast called blood
bath that you can check out
she's a real heartbeat in the world and
we're happy to have her here today
miss kalylah
i'll sit and tell you my stories
[Applause]
you're always one of the the comics that
i always felt like
well i like him which is kind of a rare
thing really
thank you i always i mean i think it's
hard whenever somebody sees you not to
be like
you know have some sort of desire
around you or something like that you
know i think you see you i think you
seem very desirable
i have a question about that yeah
especially to a white man or semi-white
i'm semi-white
does the question of desirability have
to do with who my partner is
like if a guy sees me yeah does the
desirability level go up because he
thinks that bobby is somehow not an
equal to me um
or like let's say i was with like a
strapping six foot four
guy okay um okay like what do you mean
like uh like a tongan or something
tongan yeah love tongans okay yeah so
you're saying so if you were like with a
big
like rugby player okay yeah yeah rugby
guy yeah yeah yeah whatever
immediately in a guy's mind would i just
be off limits would you be off limits if
i saw you with him
versus you seeing me with my little yeah
my little boiled egg
do you know what i mean like this at
math i mean i just know bobby has
i just i feel like with bobby there's
more of and i say this only out of
respect i love bobby and
you know i hope i get to be a pallbearer
at his funeral if anything ever happens
too much i hope nothing
he said i thought you were going to say
a wedding
don't please don't wish him that sorry i
would never wish him death i'll kill
myself
i will say this though and i say it out
of love and respect and i tell this a
lot
he is more light you can tell that death
looks for him a little
you know like he's had some of the
addiction stuff he's had
you know he's uh very he looks very
you know he looks really like a strong
shellfish would kill him
to be honest but what i'm saying is so
when you see my strong shellfish we're
talking like a big lobster with a big
carapace
you're talking like spiny lobster
no i'm no no i'm talking like something
food poisoning
i was thinking that a lobster would
attack him in the ocean
i mean i could see a lobster attacking
him at maybe like a pool like a hampton
but
uh god you have a beautiful laugh too
but i think alastair attacking him like
at a no i was thinking more him eating a
bad shrimp or having a bad piece of pork
somewhere
oh okay you know especially with you
guys combining forces
of you guys come from a very background
of a lot of street food it's very
popular in your cultures
and so i think that doubles the chances
of somebody well he has an american
stomach
i don't care what his culture is that
thing is not
steel clad that's not metal clad he has
diarrhea all day long oh yeah
on oatmeal
[Laughter]
he actually looks like where diarrhea
started
if somebody were to i don't know if they
can trace it but i could see
suddenly the fuzz just showing up in
y'all's door i mean taking it down and
bobby's just on the john
you notice looking up he can't get
anything he can't keep anything down it
seems
it's just intractable diarrhea all day
long it's unbelievable
um well you know so here's what i do
think i think when you see a guy
when you see a girl like you with bobby
and i love bobby and bobby's probably
one of my
50 probably 40 favorite people i would
bet 30.
30 top 30. but you you think bobby is
more
prone to death i think than if i saw you
with like a big six foot guy that guy
seems like always going to live forever
so bobby there's not in a bad way you
know i know i'm sure bobby's gonna live
for a long time
but you just see him as being like oh
anything could happen he
you know he drives and plays games he
just he puts himself in dangerous ways
so i think
then there's allows a little more room
for who
is going to care for this woman if
something ever happened to him
and not in a bad way but if and so it's
out of love i think that you look and
say okay
whereas if i saw you with some guy like
bill clinton like a young bill clinton
or something
then i think i would be like oh man you
know
even after he dies he'll still be able
to take care of her well i think that
well i don't know if ghost bobby could
hold you down is what i'm saying
uh i don't know can somebody help me out
here
i think bobby would haunt this [ __ ] out
of both of us yeah that's
true i mean if you're he
i don't know what you're trying to say
theo but you're saying
are you are you in line to catch me
should he die
are you the man to take care of this
woman and
this damsel in distress what is this
like is this a proposal
no i i this is what i wanted to actually
um hash out with you
okay for some reason i get a barrage of
messages
okay and what does barrage mean that's
french isn't it barrage it could be
just always messages pertaining or
accusatory messages thinking that you
and i are in some sort of
um that you're my side piece that you're
my second
and i don't know where that comes from
because i don't feel like we've ever
talked about it on our podcast or have
we
i have never said anything like that i
mean i don't know if they
do you feel like there's any attraction
between us or no i
i personally don't think so
but i like you a lot so i said do you
feel like there is i don't mean that in
a bad way
okay here let me try to break this down
in like a really transparent way i want
to be honest
um there are people that i walk past
that i feel like an instant like
chemistry with
i'm not threatened by that feeling at
all i just kind of like clock it
and then you know it's it's it validates
that i'm human
um i do have it with certain people in
his life but not you
okay okay um you probably a sad sound
do you have any sad sounds cute
because you you feel more like family
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
know louisiana's not
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what bobby
always says so here's what i'm saying
is all right um
no i i yeah i just i think that
i i guess when i look at you and bobby
what was the original question really
if if dudes calculate in their mind some
a woman's desirability based
on who she's with like okay
i don't think you know that's a good
question do guys calculate a woman's
desirability
based on who she's with i think well
some girls you see
and you can just tell a lot of time
some girls i think you see sometimes and
it looks like
a money type of thing well a lot of
people assume that about me
about you and bobby yeah of course like
that's the immediate assumption which i
think is really unfair because
i think bobby's really cute like i've
always been into short fat boys like
that's my type
yeah bobby's undeniably cute bobby
probably
bobby it's crazy bobby even bobby versus
black baby i'd pick bob
and that's wild you don't use a black
baby one babies are the cutest yeah i'm
saying
paper rocks black baby black maybe wins
every time dude but you do paper
bobby black baby dude bobby bobby beats
bike baby sometimes man
um so i agree i think he's definitely
that he's that tamagotchi he's one step
past that tamagotchi he's like the
shedding tamagotchi you know he's like
the
he's that living um
he's like dragon ball z
like five z's you know like a sleeping
dragon ball yeah he's
do you watch anime i do watch a little
bit of it i like to look at drawings a
lot
oh but you don't watch like anime like
i've seen it but when i was in college i
used to watch some of it me and my
friend used to watch some of it and i
used to borrow a lot of his clothes too
i'm deep into this one i think you
should watch what it's called attack on
titan
attack on titan yeah okay i think you
should but
um i'll watch it since you suggested it
but yes bobby is a
clutches how you say i used to say
tamaguchi oh really tamaguchi
gucci is like a rich thing i think it's
like oh it's like
it's like you know it'll leave you in an
instant dude if you don't make money
do you know that there's a cemetery um
specifically for tamagotchis apparently
and it's in america it's like somewhere
in virginia
where people where you can go and and
basically like
lay your tamagotchi to rest yeah no i
didn't know that
it's a pet cemetery oh i don't even know
that it's cool for like
something digital yeah i remember they
had a bunch of uh there you go right
there
digital cemetery that's probably
good for the environment why not dude
i think richmond can use anything it can
get right now
um but that's such a good question do i
see
a woman or a man sometimes you think i
think once you get to know them you can
tell if it's about love or not you know
i think that kind of happens you know i
want to know what you thought when
you first met me or even i thought you
guys met online
i mean for sure for sure because that's
what i thought
and you were right we did because i
lived in a i lived
oh an hour away from here i was in long
beach you were yeah okay so i thought oh
they met
these people met online and
um i wouldn't know those words i wanted
the worst thing you thought about me
oh i don't think it was i never thought
nothing bad like what would i even think
that could be bad like you got a tag bar
or something you were in a fight
i always i always wonder like like you
know when you try to again it's a
calculation thing like
oh she has to she has to be really
stupid or she has to be this
or she has to have really bad breath or
her her [ __ ] is made of
you know has teeth in it like i don't
know like what dudes think
like when they try to weigh out why i
would be
with my little munchkin look i i mean
i love bobby's one of the best you know
bobby's one of the best comedians that i
he's one of the most
bobby's one of the most entertaining man
that i've ever known
so i could easily see why
a woman would like him i like him i'm
not even a woman
so i could easily see if i was a woman
why wouldn't why wouldn't i still like
him i would still like him i think
i would not i don't think i'd have sex
with bobby i would feel uncomfortable
having sex with bobby he reminds me of
like kind of like a um
but that's me i'm also a man and he's
neither one of us is a gay man
so i think what i'm trying to say is
that i didn't think anything bad of you
at all i thought
oh wow bobby met this girl probably
online
you know because he doesn't go out and
do anything so that's the only reason i
thought that
i thought either that he must have met
her online or he got like a
i don't want to say like a postmates or
somebody got a postmates and you showed
up you know he got
hella lucky off a burrito like that's
what i was thinking
and so
that's all i thought and i and then i
just thought oh this is awesome you know
i'm glad that bobby has somebody that's
really cool
and then it's also i mean you're just
nice to look at you remind me of like
the
if they met a female female jungle book
who would be in it you know mowgli
yeah if they had a female mowgli you
know not too far off from that they
yeah i don't know what the name would be
i don't know what female mo i don't know
what mowgli means what does mowgli mean
can you look that up nick
isn't he south asian so yeah because
there was a tiger involved bagheera
right yeah oh no shir khan so it had to
have been
indian yeah sure the gyro was the
panther
and then baloo is the bear yeah mowgli
means wild child
welcome wild child so i think i thought
i'd use like a female mowgli type
and then i didn't know anything else you
know bobby i don't see bobby super much
so he's kind of secretive you know
he's like a spy that's not doing a good
job but he's still being a spot he's
hard to get to know
yeah he really it's hard to get to know
you know and and and i know that
you know i think i suffer from some of
the same things he does so i think i'm
also hard to get to know and so
i recognize that about him and he's also
it's kind of like the blessing and a
curse of having so much
like there's so much going on with both
there's like
it's adult adhd it's an it's also like a
living form of it like never has adult
adhd usually it's non-transferable well
with bobby it's like oh my god
you might catch it
this [ __ ] is going door-to-door right
now
but when you see him he's so he's so
like
he's like this archipelago of uh
of like [ __ ] and like claire's
boutique
and creativity and like drawings
and nudity and you know
you know everything he's just this thing
of everything
so it's it's very easy to be
enamored by him but also you're so it's
he's so engaging in such a character
that it's almost you want to see
so much you want so much of whatever it
is that i could imagine if i were him
that it's hard to be a regular person
behind it i think so or within it
especially why would you be a regular
person
when whatever else you are which is also
you
is so rewarding and has been rewarded
that's that's the thing we get into that
a lot because it's like
you know with me like the rule is like
you got to take your mask off at the
door
because i don't really care for like the
bells and whistles i don't care for him
to make me laugh like that's
like i already know all these things i
know who he is to right the public
like and i think that's where i feel
very
blessed to know a part of him that no
one will ever see
oh yeah because he is just a sweetheart
and the kindest
man most generous person like i've ever
met i think yeah
um yeah he's always surprisingly kind
he's so he
he i find him to be surprisingly kind at
times yeah but he has a hard time
when you need him he's there he has a
hard time
um not putting on he feels like he has
to be
something every time he walks out the
door he has to put on a performance and
i'm like well no you don't have to not
around like your friends but all his
friends are you guys like
people that you know you have to be
friends yeah and then you also create
this world of podcasting where you're
always doing so you know so
then that kind of like doesn't
perpetuate it it's still
um do you get confused do i get confused
about how about like
you know because we podcast so much and
so many hours of ourselves are out there
do you ever get confused about like
who you are outside of this like in
terms of like
being who you like authentically are oh
sometimes yeah
sometimes i think so we had a question
that came out and i want to get back to
your question kalo
and we had a question that came in from
oh god right here that's why right here
hey kalala my name's ryan uh my question
for kalila is
does bobby joke around with you a lot at
home and if he does is it easy to tell
when he's joking
oh yeah let me know gang gang blood
stuff
gang gang is it hard to tell when he's
choking did he say he said joking
always choking by the way i could easily
always the plumbing on the guy
is backed up it's backed up it's back
down it's unbelievably poor
it's like go get him bored out there's
two things that happen every day in the
house
multiple times a day he trips on the
stairs yeah and it was a big ow
i stubbed my toe every [ __ ] day and
there's always
a distant sound of choking oh yeah
and there's always me saying are you
okay and then him getting mad like this
is just how
i eat like you know not everyone chokes
every time they eat
yeah it's a real art you know i mean the
guy that's the thing and that's why i go
back to he's on the cusp
of i don't want to he's just a risky
he's a re he is he is
he's a shooting star you know he is a
star and sometimes stars shoot
too far and they burn explode it's just
risky you know what i'm saying
risky behavior he's choking already in
this conversation he's choking he has
dysentery he's probably dehydrated right
now somewhere
and trying to solve it with some type of
a mountain dew right so to answer this
guy's question
yeah i um he
he is not always joking at home he cries
a lot yeah
he's a big crier he cries every day and
it's always about
um an american idol contestant oh yeah
um something or like he he watches a lot
of like um
um families reuniting oh yeah i watch a
lot of that
like i watch a lot of those air force
dad comes home a lot of videos when i
need to
get up in the morning oh there's one i
want to send you it's a good one it's
about um
two cambodian sisters like like sep
uh they were separated during like the
war during like the khmer rouge
and that was a good one i cried we both
cried for three days but there's not a
lot of joking a lot of crying at home
oh that one the second one families
reunited
it's that one wow it's one of the
biggest tv shows in cambodia oh please
watch that theo
it's so good it's not a dream pulls in
massive
houses beautiful looking reunites
[Music]
this is reality tv with ambition healing
wounds from one of cambodia's darkest
and most painful legacies that's
powerful
is bobby in this
could be four decades ago
cambodia suffered one of the worst
atrocities of the 20th century are we
gonna watch the whole thing
um i'm gonna nick i'm gonna send you a
video of bobby reacting to this video
that you can
[Music]
please thank you thank you for that um
yeah what was that guy's question oh is
what's bobby like at home joking
um so what kind of role do you play at
home then do you feel like
um i think i have to be reluctantly and
very begrudgingly
i have to be the responsible adult
because i
i don't want to be a responsible adult
all the time like i want someone to
i want to be reckless and i want someone
to be like hey don't do that
yeah but someone's got to be it so i got
to put fi
we've had so many close calls in terms
of like fires
because he just flicks that cigarette on
you know fire season and
i've had to put out fires at home that's
why i think when you see you with bobby
or whether it's a big tongan whoever it
is
it's not whoever that man is it's just
like
oh how is she gonna survive when this
guy
gives into the avalanche the food
poisoning
not too racist but the typhoon or the
you know bad moon rising or whatever it
is or the tiger in the
woods you know how does it end for this
guy
this risky guy i bet you he's a
cockroach i bet you he lives 20 days
without a head-on
yeah that's who he is i'm surprised he's
not in a baby bjorn when you guys walk
into a place that you don't have in one
of those things
you know oh if i could i would yeah i
absolutely would
but um yeah so anyway yeah i don't know
how i don't know if rumors came up that
we
there was some sort of connection but
i'm glad that maybe people read it maybe
people read something we're not seeing
and
um i don't know i i get a lot of those
messages do you
in fact um when you tagged me yesterday
on your story those are the type of
messages that i got
unbelievable well what do people know
you know what do you think i mean
thousands of people have no i mean
they're
just guessing and people guessing and
uh here's this guy from napoleon
dynamite
good afternoon to you theo vaughn and uh
kalila kay
i wanted to ask you kaleila if uh how do
you feel and cope with all the trash
talking on the internet dude
um because i'd be peeking into the forum
sometimes and a lot of these things are
are mean but they're nice ones too you
know don't get it twisted
a lot of mean things how do you cope
with that thank you hope he is having a
nice one
i think they call his mustache i think
they call it cantinflas
oh really i think so that is a good one
and that's
very traditional huh that is pretty
traditional
you know the sunshine he's my type he is
hell yeah yeah that guy is my type 100
i could easily do facial reconstruction
don't they do it in the philippines
don't they do that
um they do dr v vicky bellow is a good
one i think
but they do the most in korea korea is
the number one in the world in terms of
like like shaving down jaw lines and
stuff like that
i would get i could do something like
that um trash talking
sunshine that's the that's the tension
right there what's a sunshine
it's a traditional japanese instrument
oh my god
he could use it for this anchen wait you
talked what the word i just said
cantinflas
uh he said it i don't know yeah when you
say cantinfo said he looks like a
sanction player
[Laughter]
i don't know how to answer this question
besides saying like what can i do
do you stay out of it do you engage with
it some people engage
in the beginning i did because it's like
you can't help but like wonder
what people are saying about you but
it's like there's i have no control of
it yeah i only have control of like
my friends and family so unfortunately
they are bad and if i were to jump into
that
it would crush my soul oh yeah i can't
live there
always disheartening in there you know
you feel disheartening down in the
internet
so when you think about like if
something ever happened to bobby right
i don't know what are you going back to
huh we're not going back i just want to
finish conversation you know what i'm
saying
and i cuz i forgot to talk about
volcanoes that's why well let's talk
about typhoons
well any of those things could happen
because philippines is part of the
pacific
rim of fire louisiana is not i know
that's what i'm saying so you guys
just the life expectancy i think
that's the big thing when you see bobby
you say oh how long well he looks like
he's still
20 years old so you have to take that
into consideration something he's
doing because there are other asians who
are 50 that don't look as young as him
that's true
so i don't know if the recklessness and
the lack of care
maybe equates to lack of stress
i bet it does probably or um he seems
stress-free
he's neurotic but he's stress-free i
don't i don't know if
that's possible but it somehow is right
now um yeah i'm just thinking like if
some so
but say something or say yeah say bye
went missing you can even say
because he also looks kidnappable a
child a child predator
no one wants those kidneys he's like
he's a smoker they don't want him for
the kidneys they want him for their sex
hell okay so he's he's being thrown into
the sex trade yeah he's getting in he
gets picked up as a kid you know what
i'm saying he's in this candy store
there's other kids in there some guys
outside of the van it takes three
bobby's in the group you know what he
would thrive in that situation he's done
a lot of meth in his life
yeah so he and that's i feel like he
would be so strategic
i feel like he would eventually be the
heidi fleiss of that sex ring
he would rise up the ranks of being once
you know anally fisted to like the head
of the
yeah champion yeah the champion you can
see that i could see him
it's almost like a um brokeback meets
fight club kind of thing you know
meets like saving like uh not saving
private ryan but like meets um
[Music]
adam that movie adam when that guy's son
went missing at the mall
adam walsh had him 22 i think it was
called
but um so dan what time if there's
somebody in the podcasting
world that i would that you feel like
you would have to shut
up not shack up jesus christ that's
respect for yourself saving silverman
right saving sovereignty who would that
man like who is the man is it a brendan
shaw type of guy
would you then you think you have to
gravitate towards like
this like burlesque kind of like
um ambient sound of a man
gun to my head because i would not date
a single comic for the rest of my life
and that's a fact look i could get a new
job
i could easily open up a bouquet shop
okay i could help okay man
easily you know i'm just trying
to get you to say that
if something ever happened i could buy
you a malt
i look i would i would put you on a
trial
period okay okay and it's just for
friendship
it's for friendship so that we would
cohabitate in the same house different
beds different rooms do all that
and then i'd see how you'd function
right and then
eventually i would see you would really
have to prove yourself
i would not be able to um but that's
okay that's all i want is the chance to
not be able to prove myself that's all
but you know what you might
if you were willing to
because bobby doesn't eat ass at all and
i love certain
certain things that he doesn't he's not
into so if you were
inclined to do stuff he wouldn't or fill
some holes
okay you might i might
consider cohabitation oh wow okay
so i guess i better
practice the brown cow work
i don't i'm not like a chronic i don't
love it all the time but like
you know three times a year oh yeah yeah
yeah you mean holidays
holidays yeah yeah yeah some stuff i
think are on the holidays they're real
real nice man
especially if people are everybody
showered up and everybody's in a good
good mood you know i could see that you
put on some easy listening
yeah what type of music do you listen to
if you think you have somebody kind of
chewing on your butt
you use some kenny rogers or something
no i don't think i'd want anything
aggressive so it would have to be like
vashti bunyan
if you can let's imagine this and see if
this feels like it would be okay for you
is this a new thing you're into theo the
shinsen no i
uh i just know about it i don't know a
lot of instruments but i know
just close your eyes
were you thinking that you are like on
all fours are you laying on your back or
how does this kind of go
i'm not into exposing my [ __ ] on all
fours in that way
it's a little bit too um so i'm on my
back
okay possibly on my side even i like
being tipped over
oh wow i feel like this is what
most of my yoga classes sound like so
but you gotta let you gotta rely
gotta get away from that
this sounds like vashti banyan there you
go
[Music]
yeah i think i think i can do it yeah
yeah yeah that's cool thank you nick
um yeah i mean i think a lot of that
just kind of remains to be seen you know
i'm open to a lot i'm opening
some different sexual proclivities for
sure but um
it just has to be you know the time it
just has to be kind of the timing has to
be right you know
i've never ever pictured you in a sexual
way like something because when i meet
anyone when i look at everyone
what do you picture me doing i i picture
you fishing
somebody told me the other day that they
i always
they i remind them of lieutenant dan but
if he still had legs
wait lieutenant dan was a hot even on a
wheelchair i would have
the prosecution rest sir
so i picture you fishing a lot okay i
like to fish
i think because i saw like one instagram
picture of you with like a tiny little
fish
uh that was a decent sized bass that was
a 3.25 ounce bat
pound bass and yes i was late caught
proud of you
i also picture you in maybe on the
toilet
um and i picture you
um to pee or to do number two you think
i think number two
oh wow yeah but i i when i look at i do
it but not a lot
i poop probably twice a week are you
serious yeah do you take magnesium
huh yeah i do for my brain do you take
do you drink enough water oh yeah i have
water all day
you eat your greens you know the human
body is how much water nick 96 percent
yeah about that so baby i gotta [ __ ]
come swim in me you feel me you know
what i'm saying i'm full
do you shoot out a lot of [ __ ] i'm full
no i don't have any
what yeah like when you shoot are you a
big unloader
yeah how much ejac do i have in me i
would say a decent amount
you know i think i'm getting near the
bottom though does it become less
less and less as you age the best joke i
ever heard some guy
said i don't even know who said it he
said
when i masturbate these days it looks
like two white guys getting out of a
submarine
hunt for the red october and i thought
that was the best joke ever
here's one of my favorite jokes what's
the last thing you want to hear when
you're giving a [ __ ] to willie nelson
what i'm not willie nelson
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you described bobby's ejac one time as a
pickup truck
truck that tipped over and two guys
climb out of the passenger window
well there you go yeah bobby does i mean
but bobby also has that very boston
cream-filled style that
you know that like i could just see him
like
i could see a truck hitting him and just
come ejaculation going everywhere
yeah i think he's you don't like seeing
come on i don't really like saying it
that much i just don't
we can say other stuff you could say
ejac
spray out bust i like stuff like that
more onomatopoeias about him out of p.s
can you say archipelago again
yeah archipelago
[Laughter]
you know the philippines is an
archipelago is it really yeah oh wow
that's crazy i don't even know that
somehow you i know you grew up in
louisiana yeah there's something about
you that feels so familiar to me
like you were like a long-lost cousin
i think it's because i don't know
but but there is something very familiar
about you i think that's why i like you
i feel comfortable
thank you around you yeah and i feel
like i've always tried to make you feel
comfortable i feel like i always have
tried to be nice to you and your
i love all your group it's that time
it's that time
it's that time to correct your kayak
if you have to you can do it handle it
handle yourself
blue chew is making waves
you know blue chew i've had a nibble on
them on one of them
and it'll get you out it'll get you
alert and get you
get your well up and it does it like
that
you don't like swallowing pills no
problem they're chewable
yup blue chew is a unique online service
delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
online prescription service no visit to
the doctor's office
no awkward conversations no waiting in
line at the pharmacy
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers
that's blue chew try blue chew free
when you use our promo code t-h-e-o let
me keep you stiffy up
that's right theo at checkout just pay
five dollars shipping
that's b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w dot com promo
code theo
to receive your first month free and we
thank blue chew
for sponsoring this podcast you know i
had a comedy show last night and i met a
fella and he said hey man i go to
therapy twice a week
and i and his buddy said i go once a
week and i said dang and they said well
thanks for talking about therapy if you
need therapy
and so it made me think that it's okay
it's okay to talk about it's okay if you
need it
you know better help b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
that's right if there's something
interfering with your happiness
or is preventing you from achieving your
goals
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online
you can get timely and thoughtful
responses you can do it over the phone
over text you can do it over facetime
that's right
better help want you to start living a
happier life today and i believe that
i've used them and i support them when
you visit their website and read their
testimonials
you can read how many people have
received better help over a million
visit betterhelp.com
theo that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com t-h-e-o
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and this past weekend listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
theo
um you have a new podcast now bloodbath
i do yes
um with annie letterman and esther
pavilion yeah and they are wild women
and here's a young fella right here this
guy could be indian
hey what's up theo what's up player from
deerfield beach
um question for auntie kalila
uh what's your favorite part about doing
the bloodbath podcast
with the girls versus tiger belly likes
what are some of the different
things that you enjoy with that also i
think that you should
rescue some cats as well as dogs i know
you've been getting a lot of dogs
cats need love too bring home bobby some
cats
can keep the cats on one floor and the
dogs on another ooh i like that
i like that guy it's almost like the
sheiks or something in um
istanbul or saudi arabia they're wives
the different wives get different floors
of the home
first wife where it goes where the first
wife i think probably upstairs
first wife is probably exhausted wants
nothing to do but wants the wealth and
the perks of
being the first wife right so i think
they probably get the hierarchy so she
has no
um [ __ ] duties none of the other
stuff she's tired she brought
young girls yeah young girls game yeah
um
the difference between doing a podcast
with bobby is that like i feel
i don't know like i i feel angrier
when i'm in tiger belly because we just
have bobby and i have that sort of like
antagonistic sort of like rapport i
guess if you can call it that
yeah yeah yeah with bloodbath it's like
they're girls
right i feel a little bit like i can
play around
i don't know i don't know how to explain
it but um i'm definitely two versions of
myself
i have absolutely two versions of myself
on those podcasts yeah
yeah i can relate to that i think it's
the same for me with this and uh king of
the sting
it doesn't feel like me it feels like me
but it's just like a
crazy version it's like i'm at a
nightclub right right
you know it's like i'm at a shitty
nightclub in jacksonville you know
jacksonville bob why do you why does
everyone have no it's actually tampa
bobby always has stories about
nightclubs in tampa and florida
oh there's a cause they'll put a
nightclub anywhere there you know you'll
have like a olive garden
you have a nightclub right next to the
zoning in that state
is unbelievable you have a mortuary next
to a strip club next to they're selling
but
bass boats you know it's like i mean you
just can't even decide if you want to
die or freaking you know
get up early for some redfish it's just
like the the choice is there they just
there's no differentiating between
anything they'll have a kindergarten
um right next to a graveyard you know
they just don't there's no
big plan i think in florida and i think
that's what florida was supposed
to be it was like it's just kind of like
this catch-all
of the united states you know um but
um i wonder what it would be like if you
were my second
if i was your second husband yeah you
planted this seed in my head
and you know i have lived with two men
before no i didn't know that
yeah before i met bobby my last
relationship was with two people we
lived together
two white men no um one was filipino
salvadorian
oh wow and the other was he was a black
guy and phil siles huh damn
and a brother yeah wow
why why do you what uh and where you
were you doing there you were just
living with them were you
paying rent yes i was paying rent okay
but wife number one no wife number one
boyfriend number one
for number two he had he slept in the
same room as me the number two because
he came in
a little later into the relationship was
um in a different room who's that the
brother
brother of my the black guy the
gentleman black gentleman no no he was
my five-year relationship oh he was the
he was the number one
he was my number you guys brought in
that salvador in a pinch hit everybody
yeah
look that's wild i mean i wonder if
we're getting more into stuff like that
you know i think one thing is
disappearing a little bit in the world
or at least there's
they're leading us to believe it is
disappearing is like ownership
of things um i you know i
while i agree with that i do think that
because i have friends who are in open
relationships
throuples all of these things for me
personally
it's emotionally exhausting i could
never be in that position again
because i thought you know my young self
i was young i was in my 20s i was like
this is so exciting
you know i get to have sex with two men
at one time
but then there's life after that and
then now you have to deal with
feelings there's you know you have to
cook an extra batch of food
oh yeah like there are things
logistically it's exhausting oh yeah
so the sex for the 10 minute sex is just
but a blip in that entire picture
yeah i mean you almost need a damn
merchant marine it sounds like to help
keep things you know like to supplement
you know the food everything the
logistics is definitely a lot
yeah um yeah i can't imagine i don't
think i wonder if i could have i can't
keep one girlfriend i don't know if i
could keep two wives
you know but i would have to just get
really really honest with them
and say look this is what's going on you
know
and that's where i kind of struggle with
women is just that communication up
front
the upfront communication they call it
what do you mean like
just telling them how things are
probably going to be up front somewhat
well why don't why do you have to tell
someone up front why can't they just
why can't you figure it out as you go
because
what you're saying today might not apply
three months down the line
certainly not how you feel right yeah
not how you feel but just like some of
your just be
your behaviors that sort of stuff you
know like again but that changes
right so it's like i don't need a
disclaimer right out the gate i just
don't need you to lie i don't like
declarations up front
because i think declarations are a red
flag i am this guy i am this kind of
don't tell me who you are just like let
me find out who you are
slowly you know because that's that's
more
like applicable to like that's
ultimately what's going to
you know um um
that's how i'm going to decide yeah what
if
i just wish i had like a family to give
a woman before we met you know what
would that pamphlet say
i would probably say good morning at the
top for sure
and then let me think it would say good
morning and then it would say
uh thanks for reading this i
am happy that you're here and i'm
looking forward to the possibilities
um i would like you to know
that i don't communicate super well a
lot of times
but i'm trying to work on it so if you
see
opportunities to help me work on it
please help me
um what else i have
i'm a one stripe white belt also in case
anything gets out of hand
i can't i i can't
definitely help it i could try to help
um
what else uh i'll do my best with sex
not making any big promises
um i like to be indoors and outdoors
i like to go out of town and stay in
town
and i like to eat two meals a day those
don't seem like difficult things that
someone would have to deal with except
for the communication part but
what do you have trouble communicating
like feelings
things matters of the heart i think so i
think i do have some stuff like that you
know
so that's why i think i just need like a
i think i just yeah i just need to have
i just need to step up and
do better at it you know okay like when
was the last time you've
been vulnerable and said like you know i
love you
like when was the last time you've ever
like been that way with a woman
like have you felt extremely vulnerable
around
a woman it's probably been a little
while i've had some vulnerable
conversations but
i tend to i think then kind of not try
to have them again sometimes you know
even though i think that it's good you
don't feel freed from it you feel
exhausted or do you feel like
look what you're being vulnerable yeah
um
no i feel freed from it it's just hard
to get to that place to do it sometimes
it's hard to really just do it you know
it's hard to do it and sometimes there's
just so much going on especially in our
lives
and i can never work out just you
answered your own question
but that's insane i feel like i mean
that even with uh i think i gave the
wrong answer then because
i just feel like that's crazy
okay bobby can die any day can you see
if bobby's alive right now is there some
sort of tracker
it's just dominoes is a good thing for
bobby
i need i need someone to pour their
heart out oh i'll pour it out
i'll pour it out in a damn dog bowl for
you i need to know i need to know
i need to know all your innards
everything about it
see i think i get scared to say i think
i i i think i just didn't know you can
do that i think i never been like a
relationship i knew you could do that
so i think it's harder now with a lot of
people you meet because it's like
i don't know man like people are really
reckless with other people's emotions
when it comes to dating and situation
ships like
it's so gray i don't know if i were to
ever jump back into
dating someone should bobby croak yeah i
would say
parish i feel like perished heroes
parish and bobby is a hero and i do want
to respect
him for all that he's done and
everything that he's been while he was
alive
i'd be i'd be helpless i wouldn't know
where to start i wouldn't know because
like
that's why you need to know in advance i
think some light outlines
of do you go for a guy like brennan shaw
do you go
for a um chris de stefano
you know wait chris destefano is a
little bit gay right
yep i'd go for someone like him i love
love
love like sexually like fluid people
okay okay so the idea of him possibly
salivating over another man turns me on
okay okay
um so he's probably out then so who else
dude i'm trying to think
um wait who who i'm sexually attracted
to
just right out the gate is jamar
neighbors yeah
100 bottom line that's just he's just my
type there's something
similar to the bobby the the vein of
being bobby
there's something really oh that
androgynous kind of like
because jamar was kind of like he kind
of wears whatever he says
he's just like the free he's a free bird
yeah he's like a young bobby to me
wow um so total opposites i feel like
bobby has that exact same hat
oh yeah that's true and i have it framed
in my home of him wearing it
yeah it's crazy i mean it's just i think
the level of uh
the tight it's just you have i mean i
just love the type of men that you love
and i think it's good um i think it's
really good and i think that
i just want to know i just want i just
feel like if you see a woman
with a man then you think as a man you
think
i think the first thing you think oh
that guy's not going to be around longer
he is going to be around long
i think that's just a natural thing
that's like nature maybe that's what you
and i
think because we come from old daddies
right right
we're both products of really old sperm
oh yeah that's true so maybe we think so
we think about
dad's dying a lot yeah right that's true
i didn't think about that
and i think just just from a genetic
standpoint i
just don't think you and i would should
have kids together
two old spermies
we shouldn't we could have a kid that's
like 60 years old
how great would that be
like a benjamin would yeah i think so
yeah i think you and i can make one yeah
oh that'd be amazing if we gave birth to
first senior citizen
and it's brian gallon
that would be the best dude he would do
it just have a new credit in town
oh i was on season one of kalila's
vagina
and bobby i want you to know i i look
we're just having a conversation here i
you don't think anything's been
inappropriate here do you no
he would laugh at all of this see that's
where i feel someone's like scared about
talking about stuff because sometimes i
just don't i think in the world no one
ever told me what's appropriate or
what's inappropriate
yeah but we've known each other long
enough to know like it's all
you know it's all love it's just again
i'll say the word you hate me
family it's all fun and games and
planning
um no but sometimes like i do wish that
bobby would be a li
a little bit more jealous he just says
he has no jealousy for me
like at all and i think that's why i'm
obsessed with him oh
i would be jealous i think i would get a
tattoo on myself
jealous man for you if you wanted me to
maybe if you didn't want me to i
wouldn't
and i would let you have the font i
don't do well with jealous people i get
really turned off by it yeah i would get
that [ __ ] but if someone
moved which someone shows like absolute
faith and confidence in me
then it's like i just become a homebody
and i i don't know there's something
really attractive about that when
somebody says absolute face and
confident faith and confidence in you
yeah yeah i could definitely do that
what else we got in it
here's a guy right here what's up theo
this is uh nico from wisconsin sure it
is amelia earhart i know who this is
they always do this a lot of missing
people hollering here good to see you
babe
um and i have a question for kalila
who um you know i think we all know she
spends a lot of time with a particular
asian fella and i imagine the people
want to know
when you know little bobbies are on the
way because
i think i think the world needs needs a
few more bobbies
if they didn't have enough already um
[Music]
you know it's starting to seem like that
house is just becoming
like a dog pound questions about dogs
leave me alone i feel like
you've been dodging the answer to this
question gang gang
have i been dodging this he's onward
brother right there i love his attitude
homer brother you go get it huh
you go get it dude i feel like i've been
very clear about where i stand on having
children i i haven't i do not know
anything about this
the same reason that you fear he's just
gonna perish
i don't fear it i think he you alone
have said
vomiting diarrhea fire being attacked by
a lobster
yeah so those a lot of things people
don't deal with on a regular basis
also i went to his birthday one time
eating very dangerous food
that was filipino food and the
restaurant was great there was fish
poisoning it was right by the interstate
there was no fish it was a steak house
well some of the steak had fins on it
so it was water steak so anyway i'm just
saying
there's that's all i'm saying is as a as
a
as a natural being if you see a woman
and a a
male it doesn't matter the ages or
anything you one of the first thoughts
is
okay is that man gonna survive with that
is that man gonna survive it's just a
survival thing
so i think that's what if i saw you with
some like you said some six foot six
rugby guy
you almost feel like oh there's no
chance that that that guy's probably
going to survive that guy could probably
beat fire
that guy could beat everything because
short people live longer
right but i think that's with short
people yes
if bobby's a safe short man wearing
safe attire wearing things that are
reflective clothing
but bobby he wears a lot of reflective
clothing
yeah you know that he always wears a
construction shirt
but no one understands why he wears but
he wears it all the time oh i do he's
under he's
under construction and his shoes are
always shining
there's always a reflector but also i've
seen him drive off many times into the
night
with no headlights on and he will
literally while it's loading
shine his candy crush game at the road
in order to see where he's going
so let's just say he lives a risky
lifestyle
can we just say he lives at risk thank
you and that is the answer to this guy's
question
i well it's compounded it's a couple
things but that's definitely one of the
reasons it's like
i need a little bit more i need him to
prove that he's going to stay alive
and that he wants to stay alive like i
don't want to be a single mom
i don't i don't want to be you know if
you are
if you are a single mom we definitely
have a fun for single moms we are more
than willing to help you out every year
we want to let you know that um but so
you so he needs to prove he's staying
alive
yeah and what else is he started to
display do you start to see some of
those fatherly characteristics
because i noticed one thing that's nice
about bobby is
like if i text bobby and say hey man i
need this
i need you here i need help i need
something he will get back to me
yes if i text anything else nothing
nothing
radio silence disappearing he told me
one time he asked he told me
he had passed away once which i was like
well you should have somebody else tell
me
because you ruined it uh to get out of
something
but otherwise he is it's odd he's one of
the most reliable guys i don't know
he is and the guy asked a question
earlier like two questions before this
about what it's like to live with him
and he's never not picked up a phone
call he's never not texted me back
like he just has a bandwidth for very
few people
but those people that he has a bandwidth
for he really comes through for
um but in terms of children that's a
whole nother ball game that that's
another human's life
um he's very good with kids and but in
five minutes spurts
and having kids is not a five minute
game like that is
it's it's a lot and i take that stuff
really really seriously so
um it's we're going through it in
therapy right now it's like we're trying
to work through
exactly like what my expectations are
you know in a partner should i have like
a child
and um yeah that's something that we're
working through but it's not out of the
question it's just
i just need just a little bit more yeah
i need to see that he wants to be alive
for
at the very least till the kid's 12
right the smoking the you know just the
reckless stuff that you're talking about
and imagine like a baby seat no
oh you know like bobby would get in it
that's the crazy part literally the kid
would be on the roof
in that little attachment to the baby
seat if bobby would be
in the baby seat that's what i'm saying
like
or like he'd leave the baby at like the
top of the car i just i don't know if i
like i know myself yeah and i don't know
if i could leave the kid
with him with a father like i should be
able to feel confident about that
that's all i'm saying is when i see him
uh certain alarms litmus papers inside
of my brain
flare up you know ammonia
gas leaks everything they're just a
propensity this
raging this rolling ball this
korean ignatius riley that's just
rolling down the hill this
tumbleweed of perfection that is just
wandering through the
through the existence bringing so much
joy to so many people
is yeah is that's just it's just it's
risque it's flammable
yes very it's flammable but i think
bobby would be a great dad
yeah you definitely and i see why also
you and bobby make such a good pair is
because
you are this loving nurturing
breast of a goddess of a human you know
you're like this breast of the lord
breast of christ
oh wait didn't you want one of my breast
implants huh
i would i would have [ __ ] i left it at
home i meant to do that oh really
because the last time you were on tiger
belly you're like let me have one of
your breasts and take it out
i do know it i wrote it down actually in
my diary well you don't have to look
very
well because i've been reading something
else you don't have to look very far
to know that they've been they're done
they used to be much bigger they were
double d's
oh damn i'm so happy that you never
really noticed
that makes me so happy looked at that
thank you i can't even
it's hard to look at anything else but
you're but you you know
and your entirety thank you appreciate
it
and i love you bobby and i'm just saying
hello just saying hello to you lady nice
to see her here today
um but what i'm trying to tell you
what are we talking about you said you
wanted to talk about volcanoes and then
we strayed
somewhere else
what is the problem here i just went to
a sex and love addiction meeting right
before that oh really
how was it what you've been going or it
was good i don't go as i i think i've
just been
like just trying to figure out with like
addiction and stuff like what is my real
problem
you know or what where do some of my
real problems stem from i think a lot of
it stems from like connection and stuff
like that like
emotional sex and love addiction like
because like
you know i go to the meetings for
alcoholics anonymous
but i don't i've never had a problem
with alcohol so it's hard to relate a
lot of times when they talk about it
but the emotional side of it i can
relate to tons it's like
whenever they talk about how they're
feeling in there i can relate to all
that when they talk about the drink and
i was so
that i can't relate to yeah i can relate
to when they talk about how they were
feeling
what about with um slaa slaa so they
talk a lot more about the emotional
stuff
it's a lot of people just talking about
like how they're feeling what was going
on like
um like
like there was uh like a guy was talking
about how
um like relationships and stuff like he
would
always like whenever somebody was like
leaving then they would
activate and like be as lovey as they
could and whenever somebody was coming
on
they would be as distant as they could
yeah and i notice all the time like i'm
always on this weird kind of spectrum
it's hard to get to like an even place
with that you know like um
i don't know that's a lot of like i
don't know but that kind of stuff is the
kind of stuff that i really dig you know
that's kind of stuff
like when it comes to your feelings i
love that kind of [ __ ] how many times
have you been
in love in your life like truly felt
like considered
this person as oh i could this could be
my life partner have you ever felt that
or
i think my first love my i was in buddy
in love with my buddy's mom
actually dude and she had i used to
sneak over another hamper it's kind of
crazy
and huff them cups bro she had this big
brazilian i'd hide in there and [ __ ]
huff them cups daddy
and just just smell that thing as hard
as i could man until my freaking lungs
almost blew out
if you see you're doing it you're really
not telling me
what like when the last time you've or
the last
time or how many times you've been like
you know
not just enamored or like lustful but
really feeling like you could
you found a life partner
uh i you know i there was a girl i was
seeing a girl for a few years that i
think
it was like it was good it was i don't
really brought to the birthday party
yep you all went to the birthday party
yeah i loved her yeah she was great
i just didn't uh i don't know i just
like
i don't know i just my own problems come
into things and i just couldn't really
commit you know
and i think almost were better as
friends maybe kind of um
yeah but after a while everyone's better
off as friends right after all it's all
friends in the end
no it really is like i i get so annoyed
like i don't know if people are telling
you people are like
when people are like we've been you know
20 years deep we're still so in love and
we have sex every day
oh [ __ ] that is disgusting dude i'll
tell you this
whoever you are wife if you freaking try
to have sex with me every day i'm
calling the [ __ ]
i will call the damn police on you it
just seems so unreasonable yeah
stay in your room too denise or whatever
your name is i don't even know yet
but that's how you gotta up the role
play you gotta up up up the role play
oh i'll take that broad to damn uh what
is it called where they fight at night
and you eat food in the stands
oh night
[ __ ] blanken that's how i feel that's
basic that's exactly how i feel during
sex that's how my erection feels all the
time
ah blanken knights in shining armor
medieval times
oh medieval times i will take that lady
to medieval times she needs a little bit
of pleasure you know what i'm saying
and i'll take her to urban night at
medieval times where she they will
get the job done that's what bobby and i
do
we do like um century basic role play
and stuff see that's awesome
we can't be we've been together for so
long for almost a decade like we have to
be someone else for each other because
the
he's tired of kalila as kalila really
yeah
i don't see how that could happen but
what do i know i'm just one man with a
diary you know that's filled up all the
pages
uh sometimes he needs a brandon
and here's dave portnoy in disguise
right here
let's hear what this guy has to say huh
do you want some of my coffee oh no
thank you i don't drink coffee
you sure am i
do i look like i need a boost i think
you look nice okay
i mean i think you look healthy and i
think you look like a woman
still no audio i don't know why nick
it's okay figure it out
um yeah you know i think sometimes i get
afraid to like talk with women about
like you think
like yeah i just get afraid to be brave
i think sometimes but i'm also realizing
that now i'm like
you just gotta talk about what you like
or what you don't like what you feel
like about sexually or anything
or even just like talk to them like
friends and if something builds from
there then great
yeah you know i think i do okay with it
i think sometimes i just like um
[Music]
i don't know it just gets scary i just
have so many i have
just a lot of weird thing just like i
don't know just someone
comforts around a lot of that kind of
[ __ ] but i keep going at it you know i
keep getting back out there
you know i dated a girl recently i think
she was like really cool
but she was kind of afraid like i don't
know i just was afraid to like commit
and say that i kind of liked her
you know i was just afraid to like hey i
really like you you know like
because i don't know what i'm afraid of
then i guess
today's episode is brought to you by
modify and the last website you will
ever need
you know we have our last website up
right now and i'm glad
oh i'm tired of the other websites i'm
ready for the last one
and i'm on it and we're doing it
theovon.com you can check it out
it was made by modify i'll tell you
about the last website plan
no cost to build no contract 45-day
turnaround
unlimited revisions and support easy
editing tools
free redesigns satisfaction guaranteed
all for just 249 a month
if it seems too good to be true well it
it really could be learn more about the
last website you'll ever need visit
modify.com
theo and get a 250 credit when you
subscribe for your world-class website
again that's modify with a
p-h-m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com t-h-e-o these guys don't
f around literally gang
also want to let you guys know we got
some uh well-designed art
that was done for us um of the
caricatures and cartoons of all your
favorite podcasters
and you can grab that now at theovon.com
there's a lot to be afraid of yeah like
you know but that you have to figure out
you know there's so many reasons why
someone wouldn't just come out and say
that they like someone number one like
like that you just don't you just
there's so many things that you can't
control after that
yeah but you have to figure that out for
yourself because you know
but but i will say and now i don't know
you in depth in depth
um i understand you
yeah i think that's why i like you a lot
you are not
a complicated math equation for me like
when i look at you when i listen to you
when i see you around people
or maybe there's just a kindred nature
between us but i get you
yeah and i feel like that about you i
think too maybe that's why i have some
like
affinity for you is because i like that
word
thank you i think we'll just leave it at
that affinity yeah
um is because i think i feel that about
you i think i
feel and also some of it is just your
people's nature
the filipino people are very yes caring
people
yeah not judgey not judgey a lot of
people
and a lot of them i will be honest have
names like linda lucky
susan but um
uh but also um yeah i think there's just
something about that it's like this
it's like a safe space i think that's
what you feel like a lot of times or
seem like
you know i've never touched your skin or
anything but i fee
you seem like a safe space so i think
that that's one thing that's kind of
nice about you
which is probably why a lot of people
will be attracted to you and i could
easily see
why you and bobby would make a perfect
fit you know yeah and i think it's good
and that's one thing i think
as i got to know you a little bit better
i was like oh bobby has like a safe
space here and that's awesome for him
you know
yeah i grew up in a very anything should
ever happen to him
god forbid we're not putting that out in
the universe one more time on this show
we're not we had a birthday party here
for remember mm-hmm
good i'm glad we want him to keep aging
we're like hey congrats on the year
yeah let's keep it let's keep it going i
like that i grew up in a really really
chaotic environment
and so it makes sense for me like
complicated people like don't
it threaten me in any way it almost
feels like
i just want to be around somebody
with that story behind them yeah i don't
want
like when i look at george kimmel love
you george love you to death
yes i i literally would not i could not
live without george
oh yeah but like i would never date him
because we would just
and i can you can hear if you listen you
can hear george's heartbreaking
congratulations on a new baby but yeah i
could not i wouldn't i wouldn't be able
to because he
grew up in a very steady um
family in a very steady upbringing with
good family good values
a lot very safe very safe yeah you know
the guy is going to put like really put
a freaking gun in your butt
yeah that's a little bit much but i
tongue tongue tongue
oh i said gun you know what i'm saying
you want ass play [ __ ] i'm just saying
look man
if we're gonna play atlanta let's play
atlanta you know what i'm saying
it's russian roulette and here's
uh dave portnoy obviously again trying
to sneak
back in in his disguise maybe he's going
to give us
a loan good to see you guys
i had a question for you i wonder how
long into dating somebody
you should start revealing bobby-isms if
you will
weird things about your life because i
find them endearing when people learn
about me but i think most women find
them to be like a super turn off
and my buddies always tell me you should
chill you know
don't reveal who you really are because
i like to do that on the first date over
drinks
um so yeah i just want to know how long
before bobby-isms can start coming out
into dating and uh he's doing he's doing
he's the bobby-ism that he's doing is
actually trying to do it up front
that's a bobby-ism it's a defense
mechanism i'm going to throw everything
out
there so you have nothing to hold over
my head and i don't think that you are
going into the situation in an honest
way oh god
i've done that for sure let me show you
all the bad things i do i'm gonna dry
shave during this fancy dinner like you
can't do that
because you really are just putting on
a show and that's not really who you are
right um
so what you're doing is already a
bobby-ism i
if you're talking about farting just
being an overall animal
yeah like that's inescapable that's an
inescapable thing to find out about
someone once you
you know are a couple months deep yeah
um i'm not
into girl hips so if you show up
on the first date and you show me your
girl hips like six months down the line
that might be a problem okay so that's
something i would like to know on the
first date
and what is girl hips like a um
occipital thing or something what is it
yeah it's not an ox
it's not an occipital thing it's
a pelvic thing okay um i'm i i like a a
v-shaped
body oh yeah i don't even care if you're
super fat or anything i just can't have
grill hips
i'll get my double legs removed for you
like this isn't about us
though but what i'm trying to say is you
hip dysplasia
like german shepherds oh like australian
shepherds i have a german shepherd i'm
fostering with double hip dysplasia
jesus christ he wobbles do the stanky
leg huh that thing sounds like you can
[ __ ]
work at a strip club it has double hip
dysplasia
dude shave its puss and put it on the
stage that's all i'm saying
but i'm saying you got to make that
money mommy um
yeah it's interesting you know it's
interesting trying to be
i'm just realizing that i need to start
to get to like
kind of i just need to be more i need to
be
i got to be more with it when it comes
to like any relationships if i want to
have something serious down the line
you know but you're not looking right
like it's something that you just want
to
um you want to stumble like you want
them in the apps or anything like that
like i'm not doing anything like that
i've considered i got on for like a
night one time and i got a little bit
scared
um and i would do it i just
i just want to make sure that like i
just don't want to waste my time that's
what i don't want to do
i don't want to be wasting my time with
some like thoughts or
you know i mean i'm just i think i'm
done with the whole
escorts thing it's just all of us just
did you do that for a while
i didn't do it for a while but if i
would get wasted or something i would do
it you know or if i would get like
you know you know i had a time a while
like not
like a few months back where i just had
like i was just like in a bad way and i
just got
you know but it never works out with him
it's always like this embarrassing
it's just always this uncomfortable
thing it's just never
i don't know none of it's ever really
ideal you know but i want to get away
from whatever feelings make me even like
get into that kind of space you know
i have a strong urge to cradle you you
really yeah oh my god
like a strong urge to just like i'll do
a damn front side piggyback
that's what my finishing moves am i
starting to move
but no i i do i do get it it's it's uh
just carry world out but i can't be
needing cradling forever you know i also
need to be able to cradle myself you
know
yeah so that's one of the things is i
have to be able to parent myself enough
in certain situations where i'm
like uh managing myself well you know
and for the most part i do
you know and nothing's perfect and
nothing's linear you can't be with
someone codependent either who thinks
that they have to fix you
right because that is just a recipe for
disaster because that's what i was for a
really long time in bobby's life we
weren't exactly like super healthy in
the beginning either
yeah because i'm somebody who's always
like what can i do like really
yeah like i'm i always want to this
thing that hangs over my head a lot i'm
like if you're not enhancing someone's
life like what are you even there for
and so i felt this like pressure to just
make sure that he was always okay
doing well feeling well and and then i
kind of left myself
behind a little bit i could see that i'm
like but it not
it's nothing he did it i did to myself
like i put those expectations on myself
and
that's that's a really dumb thing to do
so you can't be with someone like that
either because i feel like
you're not you're going to want out
immediately yeah i might
i certainly might this lady right here
seems like she's great eyebrows
what's up theo what's up kala mommy it's
kyla
i am coming to you guys from abbotsford
british columbia canada
we're about an hour outside of vancouver
okay uh i'm coming to you with a [ __ ]
marry kill today for kalila
but before i get into it i just wanted
to let you guys know uh how much i love
you both theo i saw you when you came to
vancouver in 2019
can't wait for the border to open so you
can come back you guys have been really
getting me through the pandy
like i said i live in canada and my
husband lives in washington
so it's been a long year oh wow romeo
and juliet
like that can't wait for it to end um
you've gotten me through some really
rough spots so i just have to say that i
love you guys and thank you so much for
doing what you do
uh the [ __ ] marry kill i have for kalila
is between
esther theo and annie and whoever you
kill i want you to tell me how you do it
thanks so much guys gang love you i got
them in there
i will say this also uh it's like
snoqualmie oh
and vancouliet that was a little
border i love things you do
yeah oh that's crazy i think snoqualmie
would be a cute name for a child
actually
snow for sure oh so cute come here come
here
a little child my child would have
scotch
my childhood have an accent i can't wait
to i mean it could if your child wants
to
i think children are going to be able to
do whatever they want they said in two
years you'll be out of a black child
even if you're not even black
that's going to flip whole blm [ __ ] on
its head fam
when i show up with black [ __ ] one
black leg one strawberry leg dude
it's on let's go
but yes let's get back to your question
thank you very much and i'm sorry you
and your husband are dealing with these
discrepancies right here
right so [ __ ] marry kill [ __ ] esther
annie and theo
oh god this is so hard and she really
shouldn't have to put me in i feel like
we've i feel like i i don't want to be
like
you do you don't feel like i've been
flirting with you do you no do you feel
like i've been flirting with you
i don't think so i i made a mistake
about saying like considering like
uh to a throuple and i have regrets
but i don't feel like we've been
flirting no i just don't want to be
inappropriate with my friend's
girlfriend let me put it to you this way
yeah if i
felt you were ever inappropriate with me
i would have never been i wouldn't do
this [ __ ]
with you thank you thank you very much i
love you so much i have so much respect
for you
i'm saying like a brother same same same
what i'm saying is
you [ __ ] marry kill [ __ ] marry kill yeah
just kill me just kill me please
no let's let's let's be authentic about
this there's you don't they don't have
dicks
okay and i'm not into [ __ ] so i would
have to [ __ ] you
all right like that that's just the
bottom line
look logistics is the logistics
and taxes facts fam because i love them
so equally annie and esther for many
different ways i'd have to just kill
them both i'm not marrying anyone
wow i'm marrying myself oh god is my
girlfriend or
or i'd marry both of them and kill no
one but that's not fair right so i just
have to kill them both god
we should do it what if we did a dating
advice podcast it'd be interesting i
feel like
ah i feel like i'd give all the wrong
advice i'd be like yeah throw in a
fourth person
in there throw in the fifth yeah yeah do
music
what's that instrument yeah the same
[ __ ] attention
[Laughter]
dude it would be a good show though
wouldn't it george you think
oh yeah that's just strictly dating
george or not
uh yeah oh wow there he is and what
about um
where do you see george in enough does
he have a wife george yes i do
oh you have a child too huh as of two
and a half weeks ago wow
brave boy congratulations man
damn you guys are moving forward every
year's podcast
we're struggling nick nick's been
shaving nick shaved earlier
he's been sleeping here at night
you look good nick oh thanks and i love
that you have a gap because i have a gap
tooth
you do i used to have a gap i could
easily get it back jamar neighbors does
the gap
he does my [ __ ] could get stuck in his
head
that's what i dream about every day
when are y'all gonna grow up
that makes my penis hurt when you say
that
i would i could never tell it's his face
if i ever saw jamar neighbors i would
just figure it out now
i would just have to look away oh no you
wouldn't
no you wouldn't what you should make is
a small clitoris you could sell to
people after shows i don't have a
massive clitoris
i didn't say you did and i would never
accuse you of that and i would never
even imagine you having that well
if i had imagined it it's just not
something it's not like
it's nothing to write home about it's a
very i have a very very like average
[ __ ] very run-of-the-mill [ __ ] rotm
the avery rotma
puss there's nothing like you couldn't
pick it out of the lineup it looks
very just okay yeah like girl next it
just
yeah you know i wish i had more hang i
wish i had like just either direction i
wish i had more of yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah we all want more we
all want this and that everybody's got
something here's a guy he's probably
been in
the military looks like or witness
protection this could be the kickoff of
your relationship advice but oh
okay here we go hey theo hey kyla
a big fan of you guys just wanted to get
your advice on a recent development i
had
i recently got left by my wife
for another woman completely blindsided
had no idea
uh yeah i guess i'll just look for any
advice you guys would give
as i move on to this next chapter of my
life
gang brother gang man well first i want
to say i love you man i'm sorry you're
going through that dude
you know it's i think it's brave you
just say it just say it in a
open forum like this and just to share
it you know um
man that just sounds heartbreaking
especially if you didn't know
uh kalila being blindsided is
my my nightmare my biggest fear is being
blindsided
i always tell bobby give me six months
notice i don't care
if i i don't even care to try to win you
back in those six months
just don't come home one day and say
we're done without giving me
giving me a chance to talk about it to
see what i've done wrong
so i completely feel you this guy is
i can't imagine that kind of pain um
but it in terms of her leaving you for a
woman
like that shouldn't be a shot to your
ego at all it just means that
she was into both or maybe she's just
coming into this realization about
herself um
i um i have nothing to say
besides i really feel for you because
that's my biggest fear
yeah if bobby were to blindside me i
would
not just murder him i would ground his
body in a blender
and eat it and then [ __ ] it out into his
brother's mouth
oh i've seen it by the way his brother
yeah like that's what i would do that's
the rage that would consume me
his brother could use the meal first of
all
and uh or and also some some vitamin d
and god bless you steve yeah i can't
wait to come back
yeah in the episode he was just in here
oh nice and um
wait did the whole drama get resolved
it's uh
it it was a wild i guess he was crying
outside the building
oh he was but it's you know it's life
man everybody goes through different
stuff and we love him and
just hope i'm the best for him i was
texting him earlier but here's what i'm
saying is this fella
if she left you for a woman yeah you got
you can't be like
it's a bummer but you weren't even
playing the same game you know what i'm
saying you're playing metal gear solid
and she's doing you know she's mario
kart
it's like you know you're late it's just
you're not even
it's like it doesn't help any but at
least yes she didn't leave you for a man
and plus this is what's supposed to
happen i hate to say it but it's just
like
whatever's going on is what's supposed
to go on you know so
it's like this is where you're at now
and
you look decent you look semi-decent at
least on this video
and um yeah i would get a little bit of
sunshine maybe and
and get back out there and meet a decent
woman what do you think kalila
i don't think that you should run out
there and [ __ ]
[ __ ] the first girl you see no because i
feel like that just makes things worse
emotionally
i think that men don't have don't
necessarily like to ruminate and sit on
feelings
but sit in it wallow in it get to know
it get to know it so well that it
doesn't hurt you anymore
wow it becomes a familiar thing that you
feel and then
a familiar thing you expect to feel when
you wake up in the morning and
one day you'll be like oh i feel it a
little bit less
and you know that's just the name of the
game it's why theo
doesn't want to get close to women yeah
it's easier man i don't know what you
were doing and maybe like
maybe it's a good time to see you you
probably could learn a lot in this you
know
you can probably learn a lot about
yourself you know see what things you
were doing good what things you weren't
this relationship just wasn't supposed
to be the one for you you know at least
not now
she's out there on a different horizon
man you know
she's uh she likes ladies and so what
you can't do is you can't be a woman
and sometimes earth-shattering things
are so
valuable like i this is going to sound
really corny because i do peloton but my
instructor the other day said this she's
like on the other side of that pain is
the growth right it's just on the other
side of that
um and i usually hate like instagram
mantras of that sort but it makes sense
yeah and it's necessary and um while i
feel for you
i also congratulate you on the growth
yeah man yeah the discomfort that's
where it's going to be wild man
is when you're feeling is taking control
of that discomfort when you feel bad go
for a run go do some things to keep your
spirits up you know this is a great
chance for you to really babysit your
own spirit
or or if you don't feel inclined to go
on a run and you want to cry it out for
a week
you get fat for a week that's okay too
whatever it is yeah or cry and run dude
like i said
you cry and run oh i would listen to oh
town because i want it all or nothing at
all oh my god literally i loved old town
what happened to them face off like i
was cutting weight for a fight
cause i want it all yeah nothing
at all when the snow were left
to fall and you reached
oh my god i love the hotel wait that
they didn't sing that abercrombie song
that was
lfo oh yeah remember that yeah that was
too much but there you go right there
ashley parker angel let's look at
go down a little bit there's a picture
of him with a skunk what is that
oh my god he's a fit spell model now i'm
busy what's that one picture over there
with the
semi-nudity is that yeah with his with
his um
raging bone does he have a
oh my god is that trevor panic
i'm joking shout out trevor penny man
trevor i love i see him sometimes and
uh i saw ashley not too long ago at my
friend matt's birthday party
oh he's doing well he used to do one of
the best impersonations of
john fitzgerald not john fitzgerald
uh who was the guy that was in hey uh
don't you want to go no i don't know
american references
would you want to go to the dance
tonight i don't know american references
oh hey we'll be in the back huh dice
no no no no it sounds like dice no it
doesn't uh
hey we'll be uh here sure babe
you know what i'm talking about the
movie grease lightning oh
john travolta travolta
john travolta he used to do the bet one
of the best john travolta person he
could have just said scientology
or you know if i was doing tom cruise i
would have said that
no but he's a scientologist is he yeah
here's his son right here
lon travolta theo and kalila it's
patrick from melbourne
just a question for the lovely lady
whether there's something about
the philippines that you really miss
which america doesn't have
uh and theo bro love the podcast huge
support for us soul
have found them getting rejected from
women a lot more since listening to it
but hey man that's life daddy gang gang
it is brother welcome welcome to the
club
but hey let us know when you do get a
dame bro we support your wins over here
this past weekend baby
um that's a great question and shout out
australia
and when's bobby going australia when
are you guys going is there a tour plan
i got to ask right now is there a tour
planned ever for you guys
there's a story about this i couldn't go
back to melbourne for a long time
because there was a boy who wanted to
kill me
oh my god that's sucking sexy man
he literally actually threatened my life
because when um he was the last guy that
i briefly briefly dated before
getting with bobby and he did he did not
take it well
and um there were lots of we're okay now
so i think that i can safely
head back to melbourne yeah um but but
yeah that was
that was a situation for a long time wow
i i and he comes from like a a family
prominent family uh with
connections so i really believe the
threat i thought i was gonna be
um yeah fish bait fish food
but fish food's almost the ultimate
romantic finish for a filipino i feel
like
let me see let me think about that back
into the tank of the lord
no i don't want to be fish food really i
want to be the apex predator would you
rather be fr
imagine you want a uh would you be fried
or something at the end how do you want
to go
i really really really love um
this thing called dangit it's like fr uh
it's dried fish oh god and it smells
real strong it's real crunchy and you
eat it with vinegar and a little bit of
chili and rice
real good stuff that dang it that dang
it yeah
um but i forgot what his question was
nick oh it's uh i don't see how
you are can even remember anything
around each other what you liked about
the philippines
oh or what you missed yeah what do you
like about the philippines
i honestly miss the people i do too and
i don't even know him
and i believe that now after talking to
you i believe that maybe my soul mate
could be a filipino woman
or semi-filipino or maybe from the
azores
azores is a is a place
or british or maybe not british but like
uh
portugal portugal actually no
yeah i think filipina um the thing i
miss most about the philippines
susan lucky linda i have
go go further we have cinderella apple
twinkle those are
the names yeah all girls i grew up with
manny pacquiao named his daughter queen
elizabeth oh that's beautiful
that is beautiful see that's what i want
in my life who doesn't want to queen
elizabeth because i'm saying filipinos
are someone alone
chipotle is your girlfriend you know
that during the pandemic a filipino
named their kid
coveted bryant oh that's awesome that's
a real name on a birth certificate
see that's what i love about filipinos
it's just like a beautiful wander
through existence it's not this de it's
not this every day doesn't have to be
this death defying act you know
here's a video right here you had to
pick one person to be the ambassador for
the human race to meet aliens who would
it be
oh this is good i'll probably pick
um probably a filipino dude i'm really
patient about filipinos
they're happy they're joyous they call
them the smiling people somewhere on the
internet
and um and every filipino i meet they're
real gracious they do a lot of senior
care centers hospice
so you don't [ __ ] who else you gonna
send out there dude
you know what i'm saying a [ __ ] drunk
you know
somebody from scotland knows somebody on
coke you can't do any of that you got to
send somebody who
is caring i think oh that's sweet
filipinos all the way there's nothing
when you go
because you're gonna come with us the
next time we go right okay and who's
us us bobby the family
i'd love to go um are y'all gonna go
yeah we went there two years
george went there really yeah oh yeah
wow
people are not not just nice and i
shouldn't say that because you know it's
like there's a long history of like us
being like held down and colonized by
spanish for 300 years so
there's there is like a colonial
mentality of
we are less we might be less let's kind
of you know revere
the white man a little bit but so while
there is that
there is more collective joy in that
third world country than i feel in
america oh
in a heartbeat especially in los angeles
though like if you get out of los
angeles i think you feel
there's a lot more comfort out in
america than there is here
i believe that maybe i i i haven't been
around
america a lot like i'm an la kid i love
it here it always
has always felt like home and that's
what i don't like the misconception
about la
is that hollywood is la right all my
friends don't belong in that industry
all my friends
are they have regular jobs they're like
that's how that's why like my heart will
always belong here
yeah because it wasn't until i met bobby
that i was introduced to this other
part of l.a yeah and there's a lot of
delusion
and a lot of um right right yes
yes does get a bad rap that because it's
just hollywood yeah how it has the most
control over the media and the power
stuff
but you go on like what's the podcast
with david sow and uh
jk news yeah you go on jk news and
immediately that's where
that's one of the first places i
realized oh my god there's a ton of
people who think just like i do
who are different cultures who aren't
hollywood-style people
who are [ __ ] awesome and this is like
la
like this is a vibe of people that's
more like l.a yeah and it's unfortunate
that like let's say for instance someone
like you because this is all
this is your job you can't escape this
part of l.a
that that's the perception you get of it
but you know it's such a vast city with
just so much like
just so many cool things about it so i'm
travis ravine for life
i'm i love l.a and she was ravine baby
walker bueller baby
i love walker bueller julio um oreos ugh
are you a dodger fan at least yeah i saw
you wear the dodger jersey and i got
excited i am a walker bueller
fan i am you had him on your show i saw
him
i'm also i think i'm a fan of a couple
of players that i know
so are you just a fan of players not
teams i think so kind of i mean i'm a
louisiana fan and we don't have a team
you know
we got a lot of like uh you know the
pelicans are our newest team in the
basketball
but i like the dodgers man and i love
their i think i love what they got going
on
this season especially against the
padres it's just such a great match up
and um mike clevenger is a buddy of mine
he pitches at the padres and
um joe musgrove who just had that no
hitter like two weeks ago
um who gets to pitch in his ho and back
in his home environment just like
i don't know i'm always i i feel so
blessed to know people that have like
such cool stories and just like
to even have a moment of their life here
there to get to like know a little bit
about them
i just feel so fortunate same way i
think i feel about bobby man every time
i'm around bobby i want him to just be
there forever you know
yeah he can be there forever when he
dies i'm gonna tax her derma mice
oh i know a guy will attack your demise
i will mount him really in our bedroom
at wall what do you mean our bedroom not
our
him and i's bedroom yeah that's what i'm
saying we can mount him on our bedroom
wall
no no i'm sleeping in my own bedroom
okay no matter where i'm at now how
about this theo
let's suppose i say theo i want you in
my life let's see if this can work out
bobby has
perished okay um but disappeared in
another realm
into a different realm but he can still
what do you call that when you're
um astral projecting oh he can still
hear us back into
his body that's been taxidermized on the
wall and that's my only stipulation is
that theo i will let you into my life
but bobby's body stays in our love lair
and he's looking over us like this okay
i would like to if he's like this i
would like to put him in a diaper and
put a bow and arrow in his hand
so he's like a cupid like he put us
together
so he believes that love should go on
that's all i ask you know but i would
never wish anything bad on him you know
i don't want that to be a thing i just
hope that he's okay you know he just
lives such a risky lifestyle well why
don't you tell him that because it
my words don't mean anything to him
anymore i'll try to tell him i had that
episode the
intervention episode about his and he
had to empty that huge junk in a bucket
of urine that he'd been keeping in
oh that's right you even had my stepdad
on
richard his name roger
he keeps changing his name yeah but that
guy was great
i told my mom before i got here i was
like where are you going i'm going to
see theo i
love theo yes yeah so you're in with a
family already if anything ever happens
to richard man or roger any of
any of her friends man i am my stepdad i
would be your stepdad
i'm almost dressed like it today
you are that's how he dresses to the
airport he always looks like he's about
to step into wimbledon court yeah
like why are you bringing that he's just
he has a look he has great hair
he it's good he's good hairy
he's had good hair in in his life in his
life he's had good hair roger
god bless him god bless you god bless
roger shout out
um i don't know him i don't know if he
kind of covered everything we got one
more question right here from a young
fella
what up theo what up kalyla what up gang
um playboy
all right what i want to know kalila is
what is the most romantic thing that
bobby has ever done for you
like ever i like this
probably let her come on this podcast is
what i was going to say but
[Applause]
that's a joke and i i need to quit
joking um romance is not a strong suit
and the fact that tell me that it's not
it just isn't
and it's something that i've come to
terms with and don't expect
um he does a lot of great things he he's
very
how do i put this he sucks at romance he
absolutely sucks at romance
um he got a guy one of his friends to
buy me flowers
for valentine's day oh that's good he
didn't even hand him to me his friend
handed them to me oh really
yeah i think he had like alex george
like say hey dude whatever
i'll venmo you right now and he was
playing video games he was playing video
games with alex and he was like hey dude
can you go out to the first florist you
see i just bring it to my door
and that's how it that's that's that's
the extent of the romance
and i i think it comes from him not
seeing it around in his life
whereas i just saw my dad
just go all out for my mom really so it
hurts me a little bit and but it's
you know there are other he makes up for
it in other ways
what do you what would your dad do with
your mom
he was just so devoted this is why i
have a hard time
this is what bobby and i struggle with
because i'm like it's not that i want
you to have a hundred percent romance
have two percent
yeah something yeah um
but my dad would have dinner for my mom
like cook for her write her poems
like um wash your underwear
hang it up on you know just hand wash
your clothes you're talking about
and when he was you know my dad was
really old but
we didn't have a car when we our first
couple years in america
and my mom had to get to work he would
do something like this where he's like
you don't take the bus today
he would call access vans because he was
eligible
for a senior ride and he would and mind
you he
he was a sick man and he was dying but
he would order the access van
get in the van with her to drop her off
at work so she wouldn't have to take
three buses there
and then wait another hour at the at her
work to go back in an access van
but that doesn't seem like a lot but he
was he
he was in his late 70s at this point
but things like that i saw mattered to
me
yeah and had such a big effect on my
life and bobby had didn't
see that so i offer him grace in that
way because
he wasn't as lucky to have it in his
life like i did
[Music]
yeah that's pretty powerful man i
remember yeah my parents didn't have
like a lot of stuff like that i saw my
parents kiss one time at like a birthday
how'd you feel and it was like my dad
like kissed my mom on the head i
remember
up here or back here back here oh
standing behind her it was okay it was
fine
how much younger was your mom uh i think
she's 38 years
38 years younger yeah my mom was 36
years younger
wow so we're twins yeah
yeah symbiotic did your dad um did your
mom carry on relationships with other
men
at all while they were seeing each other
mean yeah no she didn't i think after
they split up she had
she ended up meeting a man but
yeah she would they just i don't know my
dad always slept on the couch
they just didn't have a vibe you know so
i think even now when i think about like
being in separate places being in
separate rooms like that kind of stuff
feels normal to me i guess you know
i think you don't realize how much those
little things when you're a kid really
like
kind of resonate with you they do of
like
i think my yeah maybe my mom had said
such discomfort with my dad being around
i don't know
maybe you're a lot more similar to bobby
in that regard because
while my parents were really um
were very different ages there was love
there
there was respect there was mutual
devotion
and um from a distance it could it
looked like a 90-day
fiance situation gone wrong like a
ritual
guy because my dad was a rich guy went
back to the philippines got himself like
young philippine hussey that wasn't the
case
my dad eventually lost all his money and
my mom never
left his side until the day he died all
her friends were like oh does he have an
inheritance
and she's not a single [ __ ] dime
because he was a poor gambler he [ __ ]
up all his investments
but she they were devoted to each other
and
that's where it becomes a situation
where
bobby doesn't require certain things in
a relationship and i do
because i yearn for that love they have
like i yearn for that
but it's nice that you're willing to at
least or you it seems like you're brave
enough to try and make that
for yourself you know even if it's not
coming in 100 from the other person
exactly like you want it
it can't though but that's that my
i can't require bobby to give me
i he can't be my one-stop shop for
everything right i have friends for that
i have a sister for that i have a mother
for that
like my emotional needs you know don't
have to be tended to by this man like
i have a whole community for that um
so in that regard i do tell him like hey
up your romance game a little bit yeah i
understand that you didn't grow up with
christmas trees or love
and you got beat up a lot but this is
what i need and this is what i know
you're able to give
so just give that two percent i'm happy
with that two percent
right so we're working on it managing
expectations wow
well learned a lot about love here today
guys i feel like
you know i really appreciate you coming
in and just talking it's so nice to talk
to a woman
for a while and not have anybody
not there be any like no expectations or
no like um
uncomfort you know i mean just like some
fun moments but i didn't really feel any
uncomfort and
you know i really feel like chatting
with you is fun because it's like an
environment where i can like learn a
little
share a little i know our listeners
really love it so
thanks theo yeah i'm really really
should we just
put it on record that we are not each
other's side pieces
yeah who would i don't know who would
ever think that so stop writing putting
it on this message
stop messaging me asking if theo has
eaten my butt because he certainly
hasn't and he'll tell you himself
yeah i mean if i had bro i would know
and he would be talking about it it's
full of flavor
oh and he would you would have liked
that blue ice vape
a hitter you know that candy that leaves
your tongue all blue
that's exactly what that is oh yeah
that's a nice bro
well that's what you should do you
should put like that bank die like they
put on the money
on your butthole that way people would
know if i had been or not
and right now if we can just edit in a
bunch of that blue dye rock
this would be a great place to end the
episode
thanks for having me theo thank you so
much you guys go check out bloodbath
with uh kalila
and uh annie letterman and esther
pavitsky
now i'm just floating on the breeze and
i feel i'm falling
like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
[Music]
[Music]
a little time
for me to set that parking brake and let
myself
on my heart shine that light on
me
i'll sit and tell you my stories
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these rails that i've been riding on
[Music]
there